dieser kosmische radio blitz ist absolut
mysteriös vier tage lang erfolgen fast
stündlicher blitze danach gibt es eine
pause von zwölf tagen dann wiederholt
sich das ganze
wer oder was steckt dahinter kommen
diese signale etwa von außerirdischen
leben oder was ist die ursache klicks um
science-fiction hier gibt es täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen das was wir bisher über die
so genannten fast ray burst fab wissen
hält sich wirklich in grenzen was
feststeht die radio blitze sind extrem
stark und ultra kurz halten nur
millisekunden und entstehen wohl
außerhalb unserer galaxie doch wie genau
das ist unklar
jetzt gibt es eine entdeckung die
wirklich super spooky ist die rede ist
von einem neu entdeckten kosmischen
radio blitz denn es handelt sich nicht
nur um einen wiederholungstäter sondern
um ein radio burst der einem
merkwürdigen und regelmäßigen takt folgt
diese entdeckung ist eine premiere denn
es handelt sich um den ersten
regelmäßigen radio burst überhaupt dazu
heißt es in der aktuellen studie eines
forschungsteams dies ist die bislang
erste und einzige beim radio burst
nachgewiesene periodizität zwar wussten
fachleute bislang bereits dass es
sogenannte wiederholungstäter gibt also
quellen die ganze serien von radiowellen
aussenden
doch diese treten wohl nur sporadisch
und unregelmäßig auf anders aber jetzt
bei der kuriosen neuentdeckungen die
signale die pünktlich alle 16 tage auf
der erde ankommen stammen wohl aus einer
spirale galaxie die 500 millionen
lichtjahre von der erde entfernt ist die
radio quelle selbst mit der bezeichnung
fab 8 10 09 16 der volle name ist unten
eingeblendet wurde bereits vor zwei
jahren 2018 durch das canadian hydro jet
intensity mapping experiment aufgespürt
ursprünglich wollten die fachleute mit
diesem kanadischen radioteleskop der
dunklen energie auf die schliche kommt
noch mittlerweile wurden schon
zahlreiche fast ray burst damit
aufgespürt aus dieser radio quelle
wurden mittlerweile 28 blitze
nachgewiesen und zwar von verschiedenen
radioteleskopen weltweit mittlerweile
steht fest dass der takt zugleich
regelmäßig und unregelmäßig ist zum
einen gibt es den grundlegenden takt der
aus vier tagen mit einer hohen akt
qualität besteht dann folgt eine pause
die etwa zwölf tage anhält die
periodizität der quelle beträgt somit
genau 16,35 tage doch hinzu kommt dass
die dichte und häufigkeit der radio
pulse innerhalb der vier aktiven tage
sehr krass variieren dabei treffen sie
dennoch relativ regelmäßig alle 1,8
stunden ein und genau diese erkenntnisse
sind für forschungsteams weltweit
superspannend dazu schreibt das
forschungsteam die entdeckung einer
solchen periodizität beeilen sich
wiederholen radio vest ist ein wichtiger
hinweis auf die natur dieses objekts
doch bislang können die vorstellen auch
daraus einfach nichts schlussfolgern
diese seltsamen eigenschaften der radio
puzzle stellt die fachwelt vor ein
riesiges rätsel denn der regelmäßig aber
zugleich auch unregelmäßige rhytmus kann
nicht mit den bislang angenommenen
entstehungsmechanismen der fas regio
börse einklang gebracht werden
bisher hatte man gemutmasst dass die
pulse aus einem sehr starken magnet
umfeld stammen gedachte man an einen
neutronenstern in der nähe eines
schwarzen lochs oder an ein magnet doch
das alles passt nicht zu dem jetzt
aufgespürten wiederholungstäter dazu
heißt es in der aktuellen studie
zwar könnte die rotation eines pulses
die periodizität erklären aber alle
bekannten pulsare in unserer galaxie
haben mutations perioden von weniger als
zwölf sekunden
das verringert die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass diese börse auf starke signale von
radio pulsaren zurückzuführen sind enorm
doch wer oder was steckt ansonsten
hinter den radio wissen ist es etwa aus
natürliches leben das us forschungsteam
kann bislang nur spekulieren sorgt
möglicherweise ein schwarzes loch
mitsamt seiner gezeitenkräfte als
auslöser für die schübe oder aber wird
die quelle durch einen stählernen
begleiter zu radio emissionen angeregt
fest steht bislang nur eine sache fab 8
10 09 16 der name ist unten eingeblendet
der volle kann nicht eindeutig
zugeordnet werden das rätsel ist durch
diese neue entdeckung sogar noch
mysteriöser geworden als es eh schon war
doch offensichtlich gibt es im weltall
nicht denen einen prozess oder dass eine
objekt das für diese sehr extremen radio
wird so sorgt somit müssen wir uns also
weiter gedulden und die weiteren
beobachtungen des periodischen radio
works faw
18 09 16 der name ist und mit
eingeblendet abwarten
die forschenden sind optimistisch dass
sie möglicherweise durch die aufnahme
anderer wellenlängenbereiche etwas
schlauer werden
neue alien spur radio blitze könnten
signale außerirdische super technologie
sein anklicken anschauen und klicks um
science-fiction abonnieren falls es
irrtümlicherweise noch nicht getan haben
sollte bis dann bleibt dran